einige dieser demonstranten haben es
dann weiter auf die karl-marx-allee
geschafft dort ist jetzt tillmann und
diesmal sollte es technisch hinhauen
diesmal weiter dass wir mit ihm sprechen
wollen
tim biermann tourist vor dem kosmos in
berlin friedrichshain
wie ist die lage dort hier sind viele
aufgebrachte demonstranten die hier in
die kamera laufen weil sie uns für die
lügen presse halten wahrscheinlich ja
die haben es hierher geschafft obwohl
sie keine masken trugen und hatten dann
vor dem kosmos da sollte das so genannte
world health summit stattfinden
eine demonstration abgehalten um gegen
die korona maßnahmen der regierung zu
protestieren und auch dagegen dass dort
experten sich austauschen sollten
darüber wie man das virus bekämpfen
könnte wie ihr jetzt seht sind hier
immer noch demonstranten die polizei hat
er mehrfach aufgefordert die örtlichkeit
zu verlassen
allerdings machen die das nicht und ich
habe heute auch wieder mit mehreren
gesprochen was denn dahinter steckt
warum sitzen hier
es kursieren die absurdesten mythen und
die krankenhausbetten in den usa seien
alle lehrer die toten seien alles
grippetoten viele hier glauben nicht an
das virus und wollen deswegen ihren mut
auf die straße tragen
das heißt vor allem sind da wie wir es
schon bei der demo ende august gesehen
haben vor allem verschwörungstheoretiker
die das ganze eigentlich für eine große
lüge beziehungsweise für eine große
erfindung halten wenn ich dich richtig
verstehe die meisten mit denen ich
gesprochen habe ja die fangen immer so
an dass sie zunächst sagen wir sind für
die frieden und die freiheit hier hat
wieder einer versucht uns bei unserer
arbeit zu hindern an unsere arbeit zu
hindern
wenn man dann einem etwas nahe fragt
sagen sie dass die eliten dahinter
stecken würden hinter diesen massnahmen
das ist eine gewollte rezension sei
damit die eliten sich das dann alles
unter den nagel reissen könnten ja dass
das ist das anders das bild was ich hier
gewonnen habe und die polizei versucht
jetzt das hier zu räumen und es fällt
auch auf die sagen auf die sind für den
frieden für die demokratie allerdings
gab es nachts auch einen brandanschlag
auf das robert koch institut
so sind nicht alle so friedlich wie sie
also dass wir vorgeben nichts klare
frage haben anstaltung jetzt
irgendwelche fiktiven fakt miteinander
verstehen also jetzt hier zum beispiel
ein demonstrant grad sagt das hat alles
nichts damit zu tun und das
robert-koch-institut er sein institut
hier in dieser stadt genauer und das war
wird kein zufall gewesen
er macht ja immer mit gerade das ist ein
bulle der hat ne knarre einer seite und
jetzt haben sie ihr sagen sie doch mal
was da immer steckt hinter den gronauer
maßnahmen der regierung was denken sie
dann ist mir scheißegal die haben mich
umbringen und da hab ich was dagegen wer
wie sie umbringen ist mir völlig egal
wer es wieder heißt das studio
angeschaut
die in der whu veröffentlichen würden
würden wir haben selber aufgenommen dann
würden sie auch selber machen
aber anständig ist was hat man so viel
hat mit dieser fans der band stück wer
steckt hinter den crooner maßnahmen die
regierung die regierung beschließt doch
die maßnahmen was ist das für eine
bescheuerte frage keine gewalt möglich
der däne zeitlich alles und sehr
friedlich
dann sagen sie doch mal wer steckt und
warum machen die das c moll ist das
schadet der wirtschaft warum also sie
haben sich mit wirtschaft auseinander
gesetzt
sie haben mitgekriegt dass seit zwei
jahren diese wirtschaft diese
weltwirtschaft angezählt ist sie sind
nicht selber als chefinspektor
draufgekommen dass diese wirtschaft eine
solche ablenkung wie eine pandemie
dieser corona pandemie sehr willkommen
ist um einen reset durchzuführen ist wer
hat denn das so von rosen research meine
güte wer hat denn was davon
das kapital natürlich wir sind doch
kapital
die machteliten haben sie wollen sie
mich verarschen
das kapital ist dasjenige wo das wo das
geld akkumuliert verstehen sehen das
geld und kapital
es sind alles konkret und meniskus über
besonders viel kapital verfügen wie zum
beispiel ein herr gates der mit seinem
kapital und die für 15 bis 20 einfluss
auf die whu hat eine whu die
demokratisch nicht legitimiert wer
steckt hinter dem alle länder die daran
teilnehmen was haben sie davon dass die
wirtschaft verstärken kann sie bitte
aufhören zu verwursten kann nicht sinn
macht eine maske zu tragen und in
funktionen zu verhindern das hilft gegen
tröpfcheninfektion hat hat überhaupt der
seite vom robert-koch-institut da gibt
es eine weite und da wird unter anderem
auch vernehmlich gesagt dass masken
keinen sinn machen bestimmt nicht
verstimmt nur dieser runde wohl besser
draußen hat es im januar noch selbst
gesagt dass die technischen daten zum
tragen von masken nicht gut
es gab es studien mittlerweile die
gezeigt haben das ist sehr gut
bis dato ghasni so und auf einmal helfen
die glauben habe ich sicher steht noch
eine andere sache
professor john juni das hat eine neue
studie herausgebracht eine globale
studie die schon verifiziert wurde also
peer reviewed nach der ist die
sterblichkeitsrate bei 0,152 sie sagen
das ist alles erschossen warum machen
warum warum geht es an diesem falle aber
die maßnahmen jetzt geht darum dass die
maßnahmen einfach grad viel zu hart sind
wenn man jetzt die sterblichkeitsrate
langsam weiß da muss man sie maßnahmen
anpassen ist es nicht wir sterben hier
nicht alle weg wer kennt dann hier sich
leute die weggestorben sind niemand es
ist einfach nicht so schlimm wie wir
mittlerweile wissen wir tun sollte also
also sie glauben die die virologen die
epidemiologen die politiker irgend sich
einfach sieht sie sehen dass es die
denken das ist einfach schlimmer ist als
es wirklich ist die was ist was ganz
kurz mal mit namen
wissen sie was das problem ist es werden
nicht alle leute gehört nicht alle
wissenschaftler sirenen von der
wissenschaft aber sie reden von ein paar
wissenschaftlern die alle das gleich zu
sagen es gibt ganz viele professoren
weltweit und auch deutschlandweit die
was ganz anderes
differenziert also wir sprechen wie
gesagt die globale studie die kennen sie
anscheinend nicht warum auch immer
warum glauben sie denn wollen die nicht
gehören ich kenne die ich kenne die ich
kenne herrn back die und so den sie
immer alle zitieren es gibt noch viel
mehr sind nicht nur aktiv
professor johann i das kenne ich nicht
ja meine haut entstehen jetzt sieht wir
sind ein wissenschaftler und sie spielen
sich auf als alleswisser und kennen noch
nicht mal die namen also also wie man
sieht es hat sich das bestätigt was ich
vorhin gesagt habe die leute haben hier
[Musik]
lernen sich möchte ich dich jetzt
unterbrechen vielen dank für deinen
einsatz ich möchte aber jetzt an erster
stelle dass du dich in sicherheit
bringen dann haben es gesehen die leute
sind erstens nicht diskussionsfähig
zweitens meiner meinung nach auf dem
völlig falschen dampfer
und drittens das wichtigste ist wie
gesagt im moment dass du dich jetzt in
sicherheit bringt wir schalten dann
demnächst nochmal zu dir vielen dank an
der stelle mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei beet schau dich jedes
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren